i'm kind of the greatest fisherman in
the entire world
besides massimo of course which luca
actor recorded most of the film from
their mom's closet
we see the final product but behind the
scenes recording remotely during a
pandemic looks very
very different than normal
this was actually the first time some of
these actors had ever done voice work
today we're checking out the performers
behind the voices that brought us disney
pixar's luca
i know your problem you got a bruno in
your head a bruno jacob trombley is only
14 years old but already a total pro in
the film world
he's done roles in live action movies
like room and wonder
however voice work is a very different
experience and discipline
for trombley it wasn't too much of an
issue anyway since he has years of
experience doing it he's been the voice
of pete for the past few years in pete
and the cat and of course he will also
be voicing flounder in the upcoming
live-action remake of the little mermaid
his animated voice really brings this
hilarious moment to life silencio bruno
valencia bruno
bro
seeing emma berman performing behind the
scenes makes it so hard to believe that
she's still pretty new to the business
this is actually her first major project
are you in town for the race
the puerto roso
while the trio may just be meeting it
feels like they're already at the
beginning of a great adventure and
friendship together emma berman's
sweetness comes through on the screen
and behind the scenes
which is extra impressive considering
she's not acting opposite anyone
jack dylan grazer has done plenty of
movies and tv shows already i've been
doing this forever but it's still early
days for grazer when it comes to voice
over performance
it's it's it's been so much fun it's
really hard it really has
so for him it was a big adjustment since
he couldn't actually look at the people
he was acting opposite however he really
got into it and as we can see was
definitely able to get his point across
luca it's simple just don't listen to
stupid bruno this pep talk works
fortunately it wasn't as drastic for
tremblay himself as it happened behind
the scenes
but he managed to portray the panic
extremely well he's dead i killed him
the worry that he'd lost his best friend
comes through perfectly in his voice
here this kind of acting should be
helpful when he's taking on flounder who
goes through plenty of panic of his own
alberto communicating the fact that he's
a sea monster could definitely be tricky
but somehow newcomer grazer does a
spot-on job it's fine i'm not human
what's even more impressive about this
performance is that it was done out of
his mom's closet very very very far from
this quaint italian town
however grazer had actually just been in
italy only two months before he
discovered he'd gotten the part filming
another project
so luckily everything in his life felt
pretty in sync and he could feel those
italian vibes wait it's called phantom
tail he'll get used to it watching
berman behind the scenes is so exciting
because she's so animated while she's
performing
we can see how it emanates what her
character does on screen perfectly julia
is an optimistic girl but even she has
her doubts about the abilities of these
sea monsters and understandably so you
can't swim you can barely ride a bike
saturn
we wouldn't be a fan of disastrous
either how alberto learned to walk so
well we're not entirely sure but he
seems pretty well versed when it comes
to it luca does have a great and
enthusiastic teacher even though his
instructions might not be the most
helpful sometimes walking is just like
swimming but with no fins or tail and
also there's no water the chemistry
between alberto and luca is really
special which is extra impressive since
the actors haven't actually met in
person that's right they developed this
beautiful on-screen friendship and all
without ever actually speaking face to
face
it was like oh wow emma berman makes for
a very good trainer maybe even better
than alberto there was no hesitancy in
getting them into shape the boys are
definitely being well prepared by her as
she's clearly thought of everything can
you dodge obstacles what if an old lady
crosses your path we would just love to
see berman and her co-stars performing
the scene live as well
learning how to ride a bike is a pretty
amazing feeling for anyone but
especially for a sea monster who let's
remember also just learned how to walk
trombley's enthusiasm radiates behind
the scenes julia said look up and then
all of a sudden i was writing it we can
see that he and luca are very similarly
animated in their performance the town
will cheer our names erkola's life will
be ruined once julia has her mind set on
something there is no turning back we
can feel just how excited not only julia
is but berman the actress herself
it was definitely really really good
the enthusiasm about working with her
new friends and feeling re-inspired
really comes through in this scene they
definitely sound like winners
that's why we gotta win
one of the sweetest moments in the whole
movie is definitely when luca describes
the dreams of his adventures with
alberto around the world
every day min alberto are gonna ride
someplace new it's a touching and tender
moment that translates beautifully to
the screen
trombley's presence comes through behind
the mic and we can hear every single
sweet note
and every night we'll sleep under the
fish
julia is one of the most organized and
determined kids that we've ever seen
i actually relate to her in some ways
considering her positivity and how well
she motivates the team it seems like
their chances are pretty good
we have one week to train bronte
they won the enthusiasm award for sure
we love seeing burman's physicality
behind the mic she embodies the
character of julia perfectly
too much my mom says sometimes i'm too
much no way not for me jim gaffigan is
usually a stand-up comedian so it makes
sense why his performance is so strong
and his comedic timing so on point all
right young man you're not fooling
anyone his sneak attack on this
unexpecting italian child brings a
hilarious moment to the movie one that
gaffigan portrays perfectly
it's time for us to go home his energy
behind the mic really amps the scene up
this moment under the fish or stars
depending on if you're a human or a sea
monster
is a pretty magical moment no matter how
you look at it
it's my favorite berman's performance is
genuine and full of sweetness
we can really understand how luca would
become so excited by the world and all
of its wonders seeing it through julia's
eyes this is how machines fly see and
they're big towns called city so cool
right when she's on land luca's mom
daniella does not hold back even her
husband lorenzo is a bit nervous by her
boldness
gaffigan's hesitant performance is very
obvious behind the mic as well honey no
i
i
don't it's amazing that his chemistry
with maya rudolph was so strong even
though they didn't get to act with each
other directly we look horrifying ugh
gross
silencio bruno that's just a dumb voice
in your head disney pixar's luca is a
film about friendship and perseverance
just like luca and alberto the creators
of this film faced numerous obstacles
from pandemic restrictions to creating
never seen before technology the lengths
that went into the creation of this film
were intense
luckily with the help of their epic cast
they were able to power through but not
without multiple silencio brunos of
course
disney and pixar have created some
animated staples like monsters inc nemo
and coco luca director enrico casarosa
followed directly in their footsteps by
inspiring the creation of new
groundbreaking technology while monsters
inc brought the ability to animate soft
hair and nemo water luca animators hit a
breakthrough when it came to the smooth
transition between human skin and fish
scales the question from day one
technically how do you go from fish
scales to human skin luca's
transformations throughout the film play
a major role and the entire team knew
that they needed to be perfect if they
wanted this film to be what enrico had
envisioned they used what is called a
transformation rig which allowed them to
turn their characters invisible now you
could lay the second character in and
make him invisible and leave just the
feet and you could pick how faded you
wanted that to be or where you wanted it
to be or not be and it was like whoa
this is so cool however cool the
technology may have been it didn't come
without its difficulties the
transformation of our sea monsters and
in particular luca was one of the
biggest challenges on our film they
initiated multiple tests and even had a
painter create a gif to try and bring
the image of the transformation they had
in their head to life after the ideas
and technology were floated around not
just the effects department but the
production team and artists they finally
figured out their masterpiece with a
little help from the animation used for
coco the blending aspects of it we
actually used a little bit of technology
from coco the new technology was even
used in developing the motion of pasta
in the film how italian after getting
the scales and human skin down packed it
was time for the animators to take a
crack at the characters because of
movement and facial expressions the two
departments needed to work together in
order to make sure the expressions of
the characters matched the
transformation does it come as an
explosion of excitement or does it
happen slowly we needed to be able to
control that they took into
consideration how the character would
react to a splash of water versus a body
of water and even analyzed marine
iguanas for inspiration on their
movements this all especially came into
play when they animated what they call
the swim sequence swim was the first
time where we were really showing off
what it means to be a sea monster and a
human and to switch back and forth
between the two this is where luca makes
the decision to go to the human world
originally the scene was supposed to be
comedic but they discovered the
potential in it after uncovering the
technology they needed for the sea
monsters in this scene they even used
the horizon to show luka's inner turmoil
horizon line is always against luka when
he's struggling and it's for him when
he's actually getting it right despite
being a sea monster enrico made it clear
that luca should always appear not
creepy
i don't want to be bitten by this guy in
order to do this they made sure their
creations were always lyrical and
decorative and made sure to include
enrico's love for childlike animation
even the sea monster to human
transformation was meant to be gentle
isn't it great
no it's bad and i'm not supposed to be
up here
good day
luckily for the animators they had
impeccable concept art drawn for them
enrico translated many of his own
experiences into the film one of those
being his love for japanese animation
specifically by hayao miyazaki he sat
down with his crew and watched projects
like the castle of cagliostro and future
boy conan we watched it together we
analyzed what can limited animation
inspire us to do so that inspiration
turned into beautiful 2d concept art
that later was translated into 3d
on-screen however director of
photography david bianchi said they
wanted to make sure that 3d animations
still reflected enrico's initial vision
it still feels like a cg film but you
can sense the hand of the artists
touching it everyone puerto rosa
pretends to believe in sea monsters
while the location of porto rosso is
based on five fishing towns on the
coastal cinquetere region of italy the
name was also a nod to japanese
animation disney released a copyright
document confirming that the name was a
play on porco rosso a film about an
italian pig pilot from the 90s aside
from japanese influence enrico also used
his love for looney tunes and took
inspiration from how the cartoon
demonstrated speed we'd have three you
know from my hand here to here to here
we would do all three of them to kind of
simulate quick speed even sean the sheep
had a part in luca in terms of how the
creators wanted to incorporate some
stop-motion vibes into the film as for
the creation of the sea monsters those
came from old renaissance maps from the
1500s and old italian sculptures they
found when they went to italy during
their pre-production research overall
enrico wanted these animations to be
unique and imperfect and even had the
computer make mistakes on purpose to
achieve his vision i love the sense that
all of our characters in some way feel
different or unusual luca's director put
his soul into the film literally the
story is loosely based on his experience
growing up in genoa with his best friend
alberto my best friend alberto was a bit
of a troublemaker alberto pushed me out
of my comfort zone and pushed me off
many cliffs metaphorically and not the
film's theme of friendship and being who
we are goes so much deeper than the
audience knows
i think he needs me
you know i can't do it without you while
the technical aspects faced many
challenges when it came to animations
the actors also faced difficulties
themselves luca is a part of the epic
collection of films that were made
during the covet 19 pandemic shout out
to raya and the last dragon the three
main characters luca alberto and julia
may have been the best of friends on
screen but off screen their actors
rarely saw one another because of
protocols some actors like jack dylan
grazer were forced to record their
voiceovers in their mom's closet
it's fine i'm not human
while he may have needed to have worked
around some sweaters and shoes his
makeshift studio seemed pretty cozy but
despite his unique studio the scenario
was still difficult for him it was
definitely a stretch for me a challenge
for me as an actor and as just a human
being not to mention he may have annoyed
his neighbors just a tad i bet my
neighbors were really freaked out about
the amount of screaming that was going
on from my house i don't know what they
were thinking as for jacob trombley who
voices luca he was a little luckier than
jack i actually started recording before
covet hit so i was able to go into the
san francisco studio and they gave me
the tour when the pandemic did arrive he
was prepared to get his closet turned
into a studio but instead was able to
safely record in a studio located in his
home city of vancouver
underdogs forever emma berman who played
julia didn't get a whole tour like jacob
but was lucky enough to record her part
in the studio as well look that's saturn
it's my favorite
they didn't get the full filming
experience but the cast still fell in
love with their characters and the story
of luca while jack and jacob just
couldn't get over how beautiful the
animation of the film turned out the
color of the sea and the sparkliness of
the sea emma fell in love and related
wholeheartedly to the character of julia
i had a really fun time playing her
because i relate to her in a lot of ways
we were both passionate about what we do
and we're also very excited and joyful
people alberto scorfano
you might think pixar's luca is just
another hit animated film but a look
behind the curtain reveals that it's not
just a movie about two teen sea monsters
it's so much more it's a motion picture
that shows us years of historical
italian legends and personal experiences
from the director himself that all led
to the true meaning behind luca ready to
find out what that meaning is
luca is yet another historical moment
for disney and pixar it's their first
film ever to solely focus on italian
culture and heritage as you can imagine
that means a lot of what we see
transpire to luca and alberto as well as
the setting has a real-life basis sure
porto rosso isn't a real italian town
however it's a near replica of the
italian fishing towns located in the
italian riviera as for the sea monsters
they exist too at least in the legends
of the italian people everyone portray
pretends to believe in sea monsters when
talking about the inspiration behind the
sea monsters director enrico casorosa
said there's a big history of sea
dragons for example one is in san
frutozo which has the famous abbey
it's a beautiful place that we
definitely took a lot of reference from
a place that is known for a dragon that
lives there along with the sea dragons
there were stories of friendly octopuses
and feisty krakens that even had
references in the film kind of sounds
interesting when it came to designing
the sea monsters they pulled out old
italian sea maps and took reference of
their illustrations however they did
have to tone down those illustrations a
little when they saw it become
overpowering in the film enrico said in
the beginning we were drawing them
really fantastical we were fascinated by
all these fins and all this weird and
kind of decorative elements on them in
the c-maps but it was like no they're
attracting too much attention to
themselves things like the fins on the
fish and the variety between them all
came from those old historical items
according to production designer daniela
strichlava they wanted to make sure they
kept the inspiration from the maps but
also be sure they were able to modify
them in order to fit each sea monster's
personality or home
the filmmakers even made sure that their
underwater scenes were in line with the
aquatic life in the mediterranean waters
and more specifically ligurian sea
isn't it great
plenty of research and personal
experience went into the making of the
film and luca as a character in fact
luca and alberto are loosely based on a
friendship enrico had while growing up
in italy he credits his past bff for
helping him come out of his shell and
get him where he is today his family
wasn't very present he couldn't do
whatever he wanted it was the perfect
friendship to get me out of my comfort
zone and help me grow up
what does that mean
no idea go find out for me will ya
the location was also chosen based on
enrico's childhood the director would
visit the italian riviera during the
summer months and his fond memories of
the towns were the reason for the
setting of lucca but of course enrico
couldn't rely on solely his own memories
to create a movie on italian culture who
wants to watch me eat a big sandwich
although he was raised there he spent
the majority of his adult life in
america that being said he put together
a team of art designers and sent them on
a mission to italy where they were
tasked with getting to know the culture
food and art in the country eriksen
thinks it's so important to get the
feeling of the place the light and the
details it has so much history the goal
visually of creating luca was to be able
to transport people to this beautiful
place that you would love to visit for
real but that you can visit through luca
that's how we're gonna see the world
[Music]
overall the goal of luca was to portray
the epic bonds of friendship enrico
wanted to make sure that the movie's
main symbolism of the importance of
friendship was at the forefront and not
sacrificed for added drama they even cut
certain scenes to make sure they kept it
in line with the vision we had much more
of a quest and we had a huge kraken
transformation at the end a big monster
finish we realized that wasn't the story
we wanted to tell all in all he was
going for a stand by me in italy vibe
luca represented the confusing and
challenging times we all experience when
we're 13. the frustration of not
identifying with your true self or
unsure how to express who you want to be
to others luca disguising himself was
actually a metaphor for that situation
and another extension of enrico's
personal experience
life is so much cooler than mine those
years where you feel odd in your own
body and you don't fit in for many
different reasons so something felt
right talking about that age with the
setting of a changeling someone actually
hiding his true self naturally because
he has to the contrast between the murky
ocean waters and wide and never-ending
human lands also helped showcase the
cramped feeling luca was experiencing as
a sea monster you just sit on it and it
takes you anywhere you want to go then
they were able to tie in the iconic
italian vespa to represent the freedom
luca had as a human fespa is freedom the
art team's research and enrico's
personal experience definitely paid off
they created a film that not only gave
representation to the beautiful italian
culture but a film about friendship and
growing pains that people around the
world can relate to what did you love
about luca thanks for watching